all this week we've been checking in on
people whose stories we've shared with
you in recent years and we've been
asking them the same question
how are you now we first introduced you
to claudette colvin last year as a
teenager she was arrested in 1955 for
telling a white lady she would not give
up her seat on a montgomery alabama bus
sound familiar well that act of defiance
was nine months before rosa parks did
the same thing in what became a turning
point in the civil rights movement
colvin's struggles have long been
overshadowed but she is now starting to
get some long overdue recognition
needing assistance now it's very nice to
meet you claudette colvin has spent most
of her 82 years as a convicted juvenile
delinquent who would go on to college
work as a nurse's aide and raise two
sons do you think of yourself as an
important figure in history no i think
of myself
as a survival of the civil rights
struggle her place in the civil rights
struggle began when she was 15 years old
at the back of a crowded montgomery
alabama bus after school with three
friends i was sitting in the session
that was allowed for
a couple of people
and this white lady came the bus driver
demanded for the four seats and this is
you and three others students yes so
three of them got up yes and you refused
so i refused because this was an elderly
white lady this was a young white lady
now that happened nine months before
rosa parks was arrested for refusing to
give up her seat on a montgomery bus
overshadowing for decades what a
teenager had also done and the traffic
patroller came to the rear of the bus
and asked me
why i wasn't sitting there i told him i
was sitting there because i paid my fare
and it's my constitutional rights
now watching this interview from a
nearby room was judge calvin williams
today he is the presiding judge of the
montgomery family court and then what
happened oh lo and behold two
squad car patrolmen stopped and you know
cut the bus off and
came they stopped and we said oh my
we invited the judge to listen in
and hear colvin's account of what the
police did to her in 1955
and he asked me why was i'm sitting
there
and i was even more defiant and i said i
paid my affair and it's my
constitutional rights
he said constitutional rights in all i
know and they put me in the squad car
and their hand caught me through the
window claudette colvin was jailed
charged with disturbing the peace
breaking segregation law and found
guilty of assaulting police officers
they said i clawed
the policemen and i kicked the police i
didn't do all of that
was it the one and only time in your
life that you've gone to jail yes
at the age of 16 she made headlines
again as one of four plaintiffs in the
lawsuit that would end alabama's bus
segregation
in the landmark browder versus gale
supreme court decision but the charge of
assaulting police officers remained fast
forward to today when judge calvin
williams in montgomery alabama read her
appeal he expunged her 66 year old
criminal record and i'm no longer a
juvenile delinquent at 82. she was not
present when the judge ruled she didn't
know his name she didn't even know what
he looked like we have a surprise
it was a surprise we have a surprise for
you what is this advice
someone would like to meet you
what's up
hello miss calvin
judge calvin williams
[Laughter]
oh my goodness on behalf of myself
and all of the judges of montgomery
offer my apology
for an injustice
that was perpetrated upon you wow this
is a surprise that was eight months ago
how are you now
i'm doing good
i heard the vice president of the united
states called you miss claudette yes
miss colvin is kamala harris how are you
you are such a role model of how at
every phase of life every stage of life
we can be
leaders in a way that like you make
history
at such an early stage of life and i
think that's so
critically important to inspire our
young leaders to have the courage to see
how they can actually change history
oh thank you thank you i wish i was
there to give you a big hug
there is more good news for miss
claudette and it includes actress sanaya
sydney i heard that they're making a
movie about you and your story yes
listen to progress well miss claudette i
got one more surprise for you
look who's here with me this is sanaya
hi miss coleman miss claudette what do
you want to say to this young woman who
will now
honor you
as she plays you in the movie
well i'm glad that she's
as beautiful as she is and i'm so proud
of you
to take time to do a very serious movies
of course i'm honored to tell your story
and i'm just honored to be able to show
the world who you were and what you did
for us and the change you did you were
the first why did you want to take it
well
i was so moved to how she was just a 15
year old girl and she had the power to
create great change
and it meant so much to me because i'm
15.
now miss colvin was not shy about
offering some theatrical coaching
i want that role
to you to show the passion when i
testified
in that courtroom amongst those
segregationist judges
i want you to have the passion and bring
out the fire
i want you to feel the spirit yeah i
want you to feel it get that passion to
say i am
an american
and this is my
constitutional rights
that i
stood up for
yes
i promise you have my word
[Music]
and again listening on the other end
judge calvin williams what has
transpired for you since we met you well
got a lot of uh recognition calls from
throughout the country it included this
message from a viewer in alabama
the graciousness the intellect
the outright
deep compassion that he showed miss
colvin
touched my heart and i'm sitting here
crying
judge you were such a change agent and i
remember judge when you sat down on the
side of miss claudette hello miss calvin
and she had a recognition
that you were african-american
i think the moment meant even more to
her did you feel that sitting on the
side of her
i did how would you phrase what that
moment
meant to you i'm a beneficiary
of what she did
by not giving up her seat and really
sparking a movement that has benefited
me all these years later in so many ways
and most importantly as a judge an
african-american judge
that could eventually right or wrong
that was perpetrated
upon her that is very significant
to me
[Music]
miss claw dead
it was an amazing story i mean listen
when you hear that man call the
voicemail of the judge and say i am
sitting at home crying
watching you do for this elder right
what you grew up learning only in
history books uh and let me tell you
friends
to sit there as a white man
and witness history happening in front
of you yeah
was emotional right it's important i
mean this is what an amazing american
life that ms colvin's had right to to be
alive at a time when the law says you
have to give up your seat and then that
same lifetime to include that judge
getting to where he is and the first
black vice president first black
president a young actress
actors portraying i mean it's just it's
we always talk about some of these
things people want to think that they're
the past but they're not these lies
continue on
it's and that's profound to think about
she said i hope i just lived long enough
to see the movie oh
about that and and and we pray we pray
you do miss claudette yeah